>> NATIONAL SECURITY LAWYERS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY WORK FOR
ME, WORK FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE SLICING AND DICING,
LOOKING AT IT SO THAT WHAT IT
MEANS.
>> WANTS EVERYTHING SO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN MAKE UP
THEIR OWN MIND.
>> NOTHING IS SO REPUGNANT AND
FRIGHTENING AS THE REPUBLICANS
ALL-OUT ASSAULT ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THE FBI.
>> Bret: HASN'T BEEN THIS MUCH
I DON'T THINK EVER.
THIS MEMO IS LIKELY COMING OUT
BUT THE FBI PUSHING BACK,
RELEASING A STATEMENT SAYING THE
FBI TAKES SERIOUSLY ITS
OBLIGATIONS TO THE FISA COURT,
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
ENTITIES TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUING INTEGRITY OF THE FISA
PROCESS.
WITH THE GUARD TO THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE'S MEMO,
THE FBI WAS PROVIDED A LIMITED
VOTED TO RELEASE IT.
AS EXPRESSED DURING OUR INITIAL
REVIEW, WE HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
MEMO'S ACCURACY.
TO WHICH THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR,
DEVIN NUNES, RESPONDED WITH "THE
MEMO CONTAINS ALL THE REVLON
FACTS ON FISA ABUSE AFTER
FIGHTING OUR DEMANDS FOR THESE
DOCUMENTS FOR MONTHS, THE FBI
DOJ NOW SEEM TO BE GOING THROUGH
A SERIES OF INCREASINGLY
RIDICULOUS, INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE EXCUSES TO AVOID
TRANSPARENCY."
WHERE ARE WE ON THIS?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
FORMER CIA ANALYST BUCK SEXTON.
PHILIP BUMP.
BILL McGURN,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" ."
THE FBI CLEARLY LAYING DOWN A
MARKER HERE, SAYING THIS IS WHAT
>> FEDERAL BUREAUCRACIES ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO SPEND THEIR
ENERGY AND TIME DEFENDING
AS YOU POINTED OUT, WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE MEMO YET SO WE ARE
DOING A LOT OF DEBATING OF
SOMETHING WE DON'T HAVE THE
FACTS ON.
I WOULD NOTE THAT AT THIS POINT
WHAT IS REALLY THE OTHER OPTION.
I'M GOING TO PRETEND THIS HASN'T
HAPPENED, THIS NATIONAL
DISCUSSION ISN'T ONGOING AND WE
TALKING ABOUT UNDERMINING FAITH
AND INSTITUTIONS.
SEEMS TO ME THAT WITHDRAWING
CONGRESS' ABILITY AND
OBLIGATIONS DO OVERSIGHT HERE
OPTIONS.
THE BETTER OPTION IS FOR HER TO
COME OUT.
DEMOCRATS CAN RESPOND, THE FBI
CAN ADD THE CONTACTS THEY THINK
IS NECESSARY IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN FINALLY KNOW THERE IS
A PRESIDENCY AT STAKE HERE.
STEPHEN >> RYAN SEEM TO INDICATE
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC VERSION OF
THE MEMO IS GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
SENATOR FEINSTEIN SAYS IT'S
CLEAR THE GOAL IS TO UNDERMINE
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION.
IF TRANSPARENCY WHERE THE
OBJECTIVE, REPUBLICANS WOULD
SUPPORT RELEASING THE DEMOCRATIC
MEMO SIMULTANEOUSLY BUT THEY ARE
BLOCKING IT.
PLAYING POLITICS WITH THE HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULDN'T PLACE
PARTISAN INTERESTS OVER OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY."
THIS SERIES OF EVENTS AS THE
SPEAKER DESCRIBES THEM.
>> I THINK THAT THE QUESTION
THAT OVERHANGS ALL OF THIS IS
THE QUESTION OF URGENCY.
WHAT IS THE URGENCY AT PLAY
HERE.
WHY IS IT THAT THE MEMO, TO THE
POINT, YES, IF YOU RELEASE THE
MEMO, THEN THE INFORMATION IS
OUT THERE.
THE FBI HAS EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE CONTENTS OF THE MENTAL
REPEATEDLY ON MORE THAN ONE
OCCASION.
TODAY ROD ROSENSTEIN INDICATED
HE SHARED THE CONCERNS THAT THE
FBI HAD.
THE QUESTION I THINK, THE
BROADER QUESTION HERE IS THE
QUESTION I THINK IS REINFORCED
BY WHAT SENATOR FEINSTEIN SAID
IS WHY ISN'T THE CASE THAT THERE
IS NO UNIFIED DOCUMENT THAT
COMES OUT POTENTIALLY FROM THE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
ARTICULATING THE CONCERNS WITH
THE FISA PROCESS AND HAVE THAT
BE THE THING THAT IS PRESENTED
TO THE PUBLIC INSTEAD OF WHAT'S
THE WORST PRODUCT.
>> I THINK THE FBI'S ARGUMENT IS
RIDICULOUS.
THEY HAVE SHIFTED THE ARGUMENT.
THEY USED TO SAY IT WAS SOURCES
AND METHODS.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING BASICALLY
WOULD BE MATERIAL EMBARRASSING
TO US.
THIS IS THE COLONEL JESSUP
REGIMENT FROM "A FEW GOOD MEN."
WE HAVE TWO QUESTIONS OVER THIS,
I DID DONALD TRUMP COLLUDE WITH
THE RUSSIANS TO STEAL THE
ELECTION IN 2016 AND DID THE FBI
AND DOJ PUT THEIR FINGERS ON THE
SCALE.
THE REMEMBER THIS IS CHRISTOPHER
WRAY IN HIS TESTIMONY FOR
CONFIRMATION SPOKE ABOUT HOW HE
COULDN'T GIVE CONGRESS
INFORMATION BECAUSE IT WAS
CLASSIFIED.
THIS GETS US BACKWARDS.
THE FBI'S ACCOUNTABLE TO WE THE
PEOPLE, CONGRESS, NOT THE OTHER
WAY AROUND.
>> Bret: IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
COMING TO A HEAD, WE ARE HEARING
IT COULD BE TOMORROW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE FOLLOWING
WILL BE IF THE FBI OBJECTIONS --
IF IT REALLY DOES MAKE THE FBI
AND THE DOJ LOOK AS BAD AS SOME
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS SUGGESTED
DUST.
>> IT GETS US INTO A CRITICAL
DISTINCTION OF THE WHITE HOUSE
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
THERE IS NO EFFORT TO UNDERMINE
WHOLESALE'S DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND ALL THAT IT DOES,
THIS IS ABOUT THE ACTIONS OF A
FEW INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE IN
VERY SENIOR LEVELS AT THOSE
INSTITUTIONS AND BRINGING THEM
TO LIGHT SO THERE CAN BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE POINT THAT WAS MADE,
CONGRESS HAS OVERSIGHT HERE.
IT'S NOT A SEPARATE AND
INDEPENDENT BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S WHY I THINK THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE HERE, DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A WORTHWHILE
COUNTERARGUMENT.
I'M NOT SAYING IT, ESPECIALLY
THAT YOU WANT YOUR OWN SAY?
>> Bret: TRYING TO SEPARATE IT
FROM THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION SEEMS A LITTLE
TOUGH.
THE SPEAKER TRIED TO WALK THAT
LINE YESTERDAY.
IT'S ALL INTERCONNECTED.
>> SEEMS TO BE.
WE SAID THIS 100 TIMES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IS IN THE
MEMO.
BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT'S BEEN RAISED
ABOUT THE MEMO IS THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE RELEASE
BECAUSE IT WILL CAST DOUBT ON
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS.
THAT'S AN ASPECT TO IT.
I THINK SPEAKER RYAN WAS TRYING
TO BE DELIBERATE IN SAYING THIS
IS SOMETHING SEPARATE FROM THAT
TO TRY AND ERASE THE SENSE THAT
MIGHT BE OUT THERE.
ALL OF THAT SAID, I THINK -- WE
OBJECTIVE ACTORS WHEREAS THE
TRAINED FBI OFFICIALS WERE
TRAINED TO ACT OBJECTIVELY ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE ACTING ON A
A LOT OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
IT PAINTED A DIFFERENT PICTURE.
>> I WOULD RATHER HEAR PEOPLE
CONCERNED ABOUT TRUTH.
THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS
RAISED ABOUT THE FBI.
IF THE FBI MISREPRESENTED
INFORMATION TO FISA COURT, THE
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE WORLD, THAT'S A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE IF THEY CHANGE THEIR 300
TO FORM, THE INTERVIEW FORM,
THAT'S A BIG DEAL TO GETS THE
HEART OF GOVERNMENT.
TO ME IT'S WORSE THAN IF A
POLITICIAN'S SCRIPT.
IF A POLITICIAN IS CORRUPT, IT'S
ONE THING.
IF THE OBJECTIVE INSTITUTIONS --
I FIND IT SO STRANGE THAT NEVER
HAVE SO MANY THOUGHTS HARD TO
PREVENT SO MUCH INFORMATION FROM
ARGUMENTS, WHETHER IT'S LACK OF
CONTACT WITH HER WAS PUT